okay sweetheart what black adam
here hold the camera hold the camera
well you're blocking the camera
you're blocking you're blocking the
thing anyway okay they can't see me they
don't need to you gotta tilt the hello
okay
what's up guys okay so
black adam black adam we just saw the
black adam teaser what do you think
i was impressed and disappointed at the
same time disappointed
yes i think it's cool i saw no cape
and i saw no point they showed the cave
they didn't show the point
but they the point like near the very
end where he's hovering there and he's
like
he's like 5 000 years like i'm free
again i didn't i didn't see that
i didn't see it it's the thing that was
hanging off the back of him and moving
if i saw it
and i didn't see because he like the
rock had the perfect hairline
to play black adam that receding hair
the whole the whole whoosh you know
yeah perfect but that that comes
the power of the wizard shazam do you
get like basically superman's powers and
a receding hair doesn't make any sense
but otherwise i loved i loved the
trailer
it looks cool it was kind of weird that
it was
like yeah there's no slo-mo like it
it looked all animated which i felt was
kind of like
isn't this a movie it wasn't supposed to
be like shazam i thought it was supposed
to be
like i think it'd be hilarious if the
whole movie was like that
i'd be mad as [ __ ] it was like kind of
an animated emotion
no that would be no it would be one of
those comics what's that comic you want
me to do with kevin grievous what was
that called
um it's his comic no no but like the
style
motion comic that's what it is it should
be like how do you not know
the name of the comic rapper it's like
adam the legend of superman that's
what it is but um but yeah no it it i
think it's going to be cool
i think so as well you think so as well
i think so as well
need some air all this talking of the
rock
helmet mariah is a huge dwayne johnson
fan
yeah i don't know like to the point
where i would pay him
to rock bottom me he could do it on
concrete i wouldn't care
rock bottom yes now when you say rock
bottom are we talking about like the
rock bottom or like
the rock ball i
mean no i mean the actual like if like
if if i would pay him good money to like
wrestle like i would meet him in a ring
i'd be like dwayne johnson you can't
rock bottom my girl man like you and me
are gonna
are gonna get into a fight now let me
tell you something and you're gonna
here's the thing here's the thing here's
the thing all right me versus dwayne
johnson
i'll get my licks in all right
i can win that [ __ ] i could take on
dwayne johnson
beat him like he stole something
you don't believe me i believe that you
believe it
that's the answer all that matters that
is not an answer that's
all that matters i believe in you and as
long as you believe in you that is all
that matters
but uh yeah no i thought that the
trailer was was
pretty good um the style threw me off a
little bit because i thought it was a
live action movie
yeah but other than that well i think it
is a live-action movie they're just
basically using placeholders for right
now
that's kind of ghetto but i mean
honestly i think they just wanted to get
something out right they just wanted to
have something out there
i feel like that's a little ghetto but
they did the best they could under the
circumstances
i mean my question is how far like how
close is the movie to being done because
i haven't really read up on it so i
don't know if like the movie is close to
being finished
or almost yeah i'm not 100 sure yet
who really knows at this point i really
i i would assume that they had started
this a few years ago but
you know the rock's been doing so much i
wouldn't be surprised if they're like a
third of the way through or haven't
hardly started yeah i know covey had hit
everything and kind of stopped
everything but
yeah i'm kind of curious i think it was
good though overall i think it was good
though we're actually at a drive-in
right now
well we're waiting to get into this
we're waiting to get into this we're not
at the drive-in yet yeah we're gonna go
see black adam at the drive-in y'all
no we're not no we're not even it'd be
cool it'd be cool if we did
but i wish
i mean i'm kind of curious did you see
okay because i read about this i don't
know if you read about this did you hear
and i'm sure you guys heard maxwell lord
is in the wonder woman movie
and that's how steve trevor comes back
apparently i wouldn't be surprised i
mean who what else what other
what other super villain would she be
fighting well so apparently cheetah is
the main villain
but i guess maxwell lord explains how
steve trevor came back that doesn't make
any sense because all maxwell lord could
do he just had telepathy he couldn't
like grant wishes right like apparently
i guess he's right he's the genie from
aladdin now right you know my hands
your hand is hurting my arm is getting
stuck is it
it's okay though we'll work that arm out
later
point is
that i wouldn't be surprised if maxwell
lord was introduced
in this movie or at least wasn't in the
end of credits
yeah i mean well he's going to be in
wonder woman so and here's here's what
i'm kind of curious about right because
honestly and this is this is what's so
cool so have you heard the rumor they're
talking about with the batman
and everything which one so ben affleck
is going to come back during the
flashpoint movie
yeah but they're also going to have
supposedly michael keaton batman and the
idea is they're going to use flashpoint
to explain
how you have all these movies like
joaquin phoenix's joker
and then you have like the like batfleck
that would make a lot of sense and
they're going to explain that like it's
all different universes
which thank god because like up until
this point i feel like everybody was
looking at it like dude dc's all over
the damn place like nobody knows what
warner brothers is doing like they don't
even
they could they could make this work
or they could [ __ ] this up i don't think
they will i think i think they'll make
it but i
i think that they could make it work
yeah it's the only explanation they
could have for
the [ __ ] show that they've endured the
last like 15 years
but here's here's the thing though man
like like okay
the way the rock looked like that that
final shot at the very end
yeah that was dope that was dope he
looks amazing as black adam he does
yeah i just really want that hairline
you want the rock's airline why do you
i don't want it but i'm saying i yes rob
cut them oh but you want the black atoms
like that because it's perfect
they'll probably end up giving it to
them i don't know it would be perfect i
mean how are they going to get it on
right because like i mean the rock's
ball i guess you can grow his hair out
the same way we i put all this hair on
my head i inherently have none and now
look
how do you put weave on a bald head
you'd be surprised
guys tired this dude just rode by he's
like i'm [ __ ] tired
random he's like a chicken man y'all got
some chicken
yo okay check this out check this out
tell you want to tell the story
telling the story no i think you tell
them you tell it better
you tell it better rob tell stories
better that's why he's paid to do it
so what i want to do here okay so so we
were on what was it we were by
ohio state no we were well kind of we
were on high street um
on short north okay so we're in the
short north um here in columbus
and uh we had walked down like we had
this amazing dinner and it was date
night wasn't it
yeah so we walked down to this ice cream
place and we were like okay we're gonna
get ice cream we gotta walk down there
we gotta walk back so we can at least
feel
good about the fact that we ate ice
cream yes we had like some kind of
exercise
anyways anyway what
so we were walking down here to go get
this ice cream i want to say it was on
the way back
up yeah it was on the way back up and
there's we saw two things
the first no that was that was actually
that was when we went to the candle
place
um we were walking back up and this like
old dude it's like old black dude comes
comes like rolling up on us on a bicycle
and like gets off his bike and he's like
y'all got chicken
and we're like i mean like he yells it
at us
right here he's like three feet away
he's like y'all got chicken
and we're like uh nah man we don't have
it he's like y'all ain't got no
chicken we're like no man
and then he just like rides off it was
so random dude it was it was the
craziest thing
when he got off the bike i got a little
apprehensive yeah
because i was like beat him up okay
because he got off of it like he was
gonna come up and say something or do
something i was like okay
i think he was gonna ask for money but
then here he comes that's for chicken
hunt
it was just with the he said it so
fervently
i was like he needed it like no and then
was
was like genuinely surprised at the fact
that we weren't just
black folk carrying chicken around town
because you know that's what black folks
do
but please walk
do we still have the though chicken
sitting in the back seat no we took it
inside oh damn
we i went and got some chicken for
breakfast i know it's ghetto i got some
buffalo chicken wings for breakfast
chicken wings man they were like eagle
talons man these things were huge
they were the biggest chicken wings i'd
ever seen these enormous wings right it
was like
it was like it was like a big they did
say jumbo wings
i just assumed jumbo meant like normal
because usually regular chicken wings at
a place are like those little wingdings
yeah like buffalo wild wings big shits
were enormous they pumped them full of
hormones
yeah it was insane although regular
chicken wings are about that big
if you're buying from the grocery store
see i've only had like the small chicken
wings like the ones well they don't
hardly have any meat on them
yeah they probably prematurely murdered
those chickens yeah they're like all
emaciated chickens rather they're like
vegan chickens
yeah i thought chickens are vegan aren't
they
they eat seeds are they vegan they don't
drink milk
or eat meat did you see the video
did you see the video of those chickens
that were eating fried chicken no
that was hilarious it was hilarious it
was these chickens like somebody sat
down fried chicken and phone and they
just started pecking at it and started
eating it
and it's like damn y'all eating one of
your own man that's sad
yeah it's wow anyway black adam
we like the trailer for black this is
why we can't do a podcast
because we get so off topic let me say
something like this is exactly why
rob and i cannot do
anything together they love it when we
get off topic
why don't we just create a podcast or
just do a youtube thing or an instagram
thing called off topic
where we see how long we stay on topic
with something and then by the end of it
we'll see if we can even remember what
we were originally talking about we
could do that
because just launch a vlog every time we
start talking about something we end up
talking about something completely
different
yeah we do we went from the black island
trailer to fried chicken
everything circles around back to right
y'all got chicken
y'all ain't got no chicken
i don't want to see him again yeah me
too like see i never got a chance to
meet the samuel jackson
from akron that's a whole nother story
that's a whole different story
are you guys all right hold on hold on
we got to do our outro we don't have an
outro
you don't have an outro i have okay but
you have to do the outro with me okay
okay with that being said guys we're
going to bring this video to an end no
you got to say it with me
okay you ready no okay
one two i'm scared why are you scared
it's just the comments explained outro
it's not a big deal it's your outro it
sounds
i feel like i'm not gonna say it right
you will say it right just say it with
me
ready one two three
with that being said guys
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end uh if you
guys are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the wrong court i promise
in the videos that i make i usually
explain comics
although it is great to see my beautiful
fiance here
a beautiful girl ah but yeah
we will catch you all later peace
i got that down